for justin trudeau it definitely could
have been worse before the campaign
polls showed growing public mistrust
with a man who won a resounding majority
just four years earlier then photographs
emerged that showed him wearing racist
blackface makeup as a young man adding
to earlier scandals about ethics and
accusations of broken promises in the
end though Canadians gave him another
chance tonight
Canadians rejected division and
negativity
they rejected cuts and austerity and
they voted in favor of a progressive
agenda and strong action on climate
change the result is disappointing for
the conservative opposition leader
Andrew Shearer who had been steadily
improving his standing with the voters
before the campaign he faced his own
challenges on the hustings accusations
of encouraging fake news and online
trolling and revelations that he had
dual u.s. Canadian citizenship and
hadn't told the voters he promised to
fight on and hold mr. Trudeau
accountable after the 2015 election when
Justin Trudeau looked unstoppable when
all the pundits and experts said it was
the beginning of another Trudeau dynasty
that he would have eight or even twelve
years in power but tonight conservatives
have put Justin Trudeau on notice and
mr. Trudeau when your government Falls
conservatives will be ready and we will
win climate change policy was a strong
issue in this election with the
Conservatives promising to scrap a
carbon tax brought in by Trudeau's
liberals and do more for the country's
oil industry but most voters disagreed
and backed candidates including liberals
who promised more aggressive steps to
fight global warming and the changing
climate
call this if you will a strong minority
government mr. Trudeau's opponents may
have the numbers to beat him in
Parliament but they're unlikely to do so
Canadians won't have to face a fresh
general election for some time to come
Daniel Locke al-jazeera
Toronto